and okay sophisticated is a great word
to describe the sterling club of las
vegas from the decor
the people the gym the restaurants the
spa you get only the best treatment
and technology
i've been doing medical aesthetics for
the last 35 years
didn't start doing this i studied a
pseudochemist in a lab
and i have a master in her biology which
is the science of herbs
that is very good because i can make my
own products and i can address any skin
type and conditions if i want to
here at the sterling we combine
technology science chemistry electricity
and of course lots of knowledge to
perform
treatment where we correct any skin type
conditions or body conditions
we we're going to demonstrate today a
little bit of
laser treatment combined with an
infrared
capsule i'm going to start with the
laser first well
eric is going to help me he's also our
laser tech here so we can do any face
treatments pigment acne or they want
rejuvenation of collagen multiplication
of hyaluronic acid whatever they want
we change the lens and then of course we
can address that problem
my absolute favor is the v-form
function and this one it is a function
that it's used
face or body through this system you
actually have the laser light goes
through and melts emulsify the fat this
treatment it's a lymph drainage as well
so we move the fat towards her excretory
system within two hours after the
treatment she will start eliminating out
of her body
that within her first treatment there is
a change
i did a treatment like this two days ago
and the customer lost two and a half
inches in one treatment because
yes in one treatment you can see results
but in order to form this completely
flat
eliminate the fat from the side
completely and
make that abdominal area firm i need
probably between four and six
treatments so we advise the clients to
sign up for
a package they also get when they sign
up a free treatment
most of the time courtesy of sterling
when they have this treatment we do
some mini facial on them and we don't
charge them for that
okay so we're going to close the capsule
we're going to set up the temperature
when we perspire we lose salt
that is trapped within our sudoriferous
gland
we lose definitely toxins it's very
important to be clean
when we have lymphatic congestion you
can see on people they have swollen
extremities from pretty much from my
experience doing these treatments i got
them from size since
14 to a size 8 and 6 treatments so when
we have customers with
weight issues we definitely know they
have sleeping patterns and sleeping
problems so therefore we combine this
kind of treatment with the led bed
the moment we put them in serotonin is
produced
they relax they went to sleep it's also
beneficial for anti-aging reactions
sterling is the only place in las vegas
that has all three systems
give the sterling club med spot spa and
med spa a call at
exact or 702-732-9700 sterlingclub.com
for more information
we'll be right back right here on las
vegas now